In exchange, I want you to tell me some
recipes and I'd like to make them for Claire-sama.Then I'll come back
here tonight, and then I'll come back here with
Claire-sama.Why do you have to come here and
make something again?It ca
n't be helped.  I'll give you a taste. I
told you not to tell Claire-sama. I'm
sorry, but I can't keep it a secret. It
gets cold at night, Claire-sama, so if it's cold, please go. Hey, hurry up and
make it.
[Music]
Okay, the crème brûlée is complete.
This is delicious. This is very delicious. It's
richer than regular pudding. I can't get
enough of the crunchy surface. I want to drink tea, so here it is.
This is the
cat. Rei-chan memorized the recipe for this mayonnaise and
threw away the notes. This is it.  Insurance If the
time ever comes that I need it, I'll use that recipe.
[Music] I
'd like to eat another one. Dear Claire, I
think it's too much. Think of it as practice and try making it again.
[Music]  It's
okay. Yeah, it's
no big deal.
[Music]
Thank you, Rei-chan.
It's good that you're in the middle. You're jealous. Kura-sama. You're in trouble. That
's wrong. Don't get carried away. Oh,
oh.